Rudy Giuliani appeared to admit how in
the 1993 mayoral election in New York
City which he won he used what he calls
a trick to suppress the Hispanic vote
except for the life of me I can't
actually understand what the hell he's
talking about because undocumented
immigrants can't vote they can't
register to vote they're not citizens so
the back story on this election is that
Rudy Giuliani won the 1993 New York City
mayoral election by about 50 000 votes
and he became the first Republican
elected mayor of New York City at that
point since John Lindsey in 1965. John
Lindsay in 65 was a republican then it
was a bunch of Democrats in New York
City as mayor and then we got Rudy
Giuliani in 1993. so we're going to take
a look at a clip Giuliani is on I guess
this is Steve bannon's show and he's
sitting between Steve Bannon and Kerry
Lake
and he explains the trick that they used
okay take a listen to this it created a
deterrent effect the fact that we did it
and John and I were talking about that
today the fact that we were doing it we
made it very public that we were doing
it and then I'll tell you one little
dirty trick okay
Republicans don't know dirty traffic how
about this one okay so they went through
Eastern World which is all Hispanic and
they gave out they gave out they gave
out little cards and the card said if
you come to vote make sure you have your
green card because ins are picking up
illegals oh my gosh so the they spread
it all over the hill after the election
the Clinton uh civil rights division
investigated me I was on vacation after
the election and I get a call from my
lawyer Denny Young And he says
uh Rudy we got uh the just Department's
investigating us uh Janet Reno is coming
after us we violated civil rights I said
Jenny you're a lawyer think about it
what civil rights do we violate they
don't have civil rights but we all we
did is prevent people who can't vote
from voting maybe we trick them but
tricking is not a crime
oh and in those days we didn't have
crazy prosecutors nowadays they probably
prosecution for it even though it isn't
and that's the way we cut down the
Hispanic vote what a powerful story huh
how Rudy miraculously heroically and
bravely suppress the Hispanic vote in
1993. now there's two stories is this a
logical strategy and did it actually
happen so the one issue with it as a
strategy of course is undocumented
immigrants can't vote they can't
register to vote so I guess the idea
here was
even if you're so like I actually don't
understand whether this is the thing
where they wrongly believe undocumented
immigrants vote because remember
undocumented immigrants can't even get
on the voter rolls because only citizens
can vote do they wrongly believe
undocumented immigrants are voting or is
the idea that they wanted to trick legal
immigrants into thinking if I don't
bring documentation that I'm here
legally they might just because of my
appearance think I'm here illegally and
if I don't have my papers on me then all
of a sudden I'll get in trouble and I
won't be able to vote so that sounds
complicated so I'll just stay home like
it's actually hard to know exactly what
the idea is but it does seem as though
this was a thing I reviewed some
documents there is a document
um from what it from the Department of
Justice from contemporaneous to when
this was going on which says the
Department of Justice and the FBI are
conducting an investigation to determine
who prepared and posted these notices
and this refers to again you go back to
a 1993 Washington Post article it says
um Justice said to be probing New York
vote suppression Justice Department
officials are investigating complaints
of efforts to keep voting down and
democratic-leaning minority
neighborhoods in the New York City
mayoral election according to sources
involved black mayor David Dinkins
Democrat was defeated by Republican
Challenger Rudolph Giuliani in a in a
contest that produced perhaps the most
racially polarized voting pattern in the
city's history among the complaints are
the placing of signs on telephone poles
and walls in Latino areas warning quote
Federal authorities and immigration
officials will be at all election sites
immigration officials will be at
locations to arrest and Deport
undocumented illegal voters this is the
key line it is unclear how the signs
would intimidate naturalized U.S
citizens the only immigrants eligible to
vote so the article accurately
identifies you're going to intimidate
people who can't vote anyway now with
what is it 30 years of hindsight
We Now understand where this went 1993
Rudy did this in the New York City
mayoral 1994 this new wave of Gingrich
republicanism took over the House of
Representatives and it's been a path
from that to where we are today
Republicans that blame society's
problems on scapegoats immigrants from
Latin America being a very popular one
they've now shifted to well we'll blame
it on trans people marxists who don't
exist or whatever else the case may be
but it's all that same idea and you can
find it back then the
um he he's telling us that he did it
he's admitting to the entire thing and
it is wild and wacky stuff